Sometimes in our apps, we want to have
certain elements at the top of the list,
such as those which were edited most
recently or that were created first.
So, when querying for records, there
are four ordering functions in Firebase.
Firebase can sort by children or
grandchildren, keys,
values of a named property, or
by its priority and key together.
Here are how these functions work.
OrderByChild)() allows us to order
by a specific descending key.
For example, if we have an item called
desserts and it contains an attribute
for types of sweeteners, we could order
all desserts based on the children.
If your sweeteners were white sugar,
agave, Stevia, coconut sugar,
honey, and molasses, this would allow
you to sort them alphabetically.
So you'd have all the agave desserts
first, followed by the others,
with white sugar last.
Similarly, in the 2.4
release of the SDK,
Firebase introduced what
it calls deep path queries.
Put simply, it's the ability to
order by any descending key,
not just direct children.
So you could have desserts, and
a child could be ingredients, and
within the ingredients object you could
have a property called sweeteners that
you could then sort by.
OrderByKey().
OrderByKey() will order the key in
ascending order by key name to produce
an alphabetical sort.
OrderByValue() will order by
the value of the child nodes.
This type of sort can be useful for
numeric values.
OrderByPriority().
The orderByPriority() method
can order by priority,
however, while it is still a supported
method in Firebase, it's not suggested.
It's a method that was used
before orderByChild() existed.
For each of these query operations,
there is a defined order by which
the values or keys are sorted.
For orderByChild() and orderByValue(),
the sort order is the following.
Return null, a value will be equal to
null if the property doesn't exist.
This is more pertinent for
orderByChild().
Then return false.
True.
Numeric values.
Then strings.
Then objects.
Why differentiate that numeric
values come before strings?
The Firebase database is
extremely flexible as to what
type of data it contains.
For example, there's nothing to say that
you can have a list of desserts all with
a child sweetener where some of the
desserts have a sweetener value that is
a number, others that have a boolean,
and still others have a string.
It would be odd, but at least
you'd know how it would be sorted.
For orderByKey(),
data is sorted in ascending order.
With keys, they can be sorted
as 32-bit integers first,
then keys with a string
value coming next.
And, as you might expect,
when you use orderByPriority,
the sort order is primarily
determined by the priority in key.
One point to note when you're
implementing sorts is that queries can
only order by one key at a time.
For example,
if you are calling orderByChild
multiple times on the same query,
an error will be thrown.
This is to keep Firebase operation
snappy and get you the data fast.
Now, you might be wondering, what
happens if I need to sort by two things?
Since Firebase doesn't support this yet,
the best way to handle this
is to use sorting to do
the first level of the sort and
then sort the data client-side
with your own Android code.
You should also consider sorting
client-side if you already
have the data available to you, because
this will save you a query call to
the Firebase database, which will save
your users money on their data plans and
keep your database from
getting pinged as much.
You won't be implementing client-side
sorting in this version of the app, but
it's an option you should be aware of.